hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone the Semitic questions for this
week's Walking Dead Q&A I think
everyone's excited to see the Alexandria
safe zone next week I know there were a
lot of questions after the teaser for
the next episode came out and everything
was empty you have to remember this is a
big community so we're probably just
gonna see it in stages the prime not
going to show the entire thing right
away so lots of stuff to talk about just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet here we go some
questions sins or s in the comics is
Alexandria good or bad I think you know
you're asking if it's like terminus or
Woodbury it's really like a city where
things happen I'll set you know good
things bad things it's just a place the
place itself isn't inherently good or
bad I think the way they present it will
leave us hanging a little bit they want
you to wonder whether or not it's going
to turn into another terminus so they'll
hang that over our heads but just in
general it's really the characters that
bring in the bad and the good so it just
depends on which characters they bring
on the show next question oh well as
nice name did anyone else see Noah
looking back when Aaron asked about his
leg I thought he heard it during the
escape not when he was with his dad or
am I wrong ya know I he was just
misleading Aaron a little bit I think he
just didn't want to talk about what
happened at the hospital so he just told
a lie to avoid that I don't think he was
trying to be sinister or anything like
that I think he just wanted to avoid a
long conversation about a really painful
memory that being said I do think that
what happened at the hospital will come
up eventually eventually someone from
the survivors will talk about it to
someone from the Alexandria safe zone
Rick talking about Woodbury is a good
example of that I mean that's all the
way back from season 3 so they'll keep
referencing stuff that happened in the
past but next question the internet asks
why isn't there any one of the safe zone
I haven't read the comics so dot dot dot
I think that they just want us to wonder
who it is we're going to meet they don't
want to reveal those characters yet in
the promo we see Carl walking through an
empty house they really want you to take
the perspective of the survivor so you
experience the safe zone in the way that
they do and they don't trust it yet so
the writers want you to feel the same
anxiety that Carl here is feeling right
now next question Lorenzo s do you think
that the producers would release an
all-out war storyline if they did it in
the theaters do you think that that
would work I did I definitely think the
idea of
TV shown in a movie theater is starting
to take off HBO's done it was very
successful that the CW did it when they
did the arrow flash crossover they
showed that in the theater but it was
like a limited event so I think we'll
see more that it just depends on what
AMC wants to do if they did do all out
war at some point or a big cinematic
event or decided to show an episode in a
movie theater it would be shown on
television first regardless just because
that's where the money is like they have
they have contracts thats a new episodes
have to air on AMC before anywhere else
so even if they did show episodes in the
theater you would still have the
opportunity to see it on TV first really
I think it's just a matter of time and
for those that have read the comics
all-out war is just a storyline from the
comics is from a long long way off
they're not anywhere close to it on the
TV show it's just like a really big
event that would lend itself well to
like a two-hour screening in a movie
theater next question Chris asks out of
the group of survivors who do you think
I'll have the toughest time adjusting to
Alexandria i would say Darryl just
because he's such a loner maybe Carol to
like they might have a hard time
adjusting to normal life or as normal as
they can get to just looking at the
promo shots for the next episode you can
see it's as close as they've ever come
to a normal community everything looks
really clean there aren't dead bodies
littered everywhere it's supposed to be
safe from walkers and they even have a
surgeon on staff that can fix Noah's leg
so I think it'll be scarier for the more
antisocial members of the group and
right now that's Carol and Daryl
although together I think that they feel
fine so as long as they stick together
as long as the group stays a group I
think we'll be fine next question the
master SAS and asks why do you think
that Rick hid the gun well I think that
once they entered with it once they
drove the cars in everyone was going to
get their weapons taken so he wanted to
hide one just in case went down
remember that last thing that Carol said
to him even though you were wrong you
were still right what she was implying
is that yes they need to trust people
but that doesn't mean that it's not
still smart to not trust people yes let
new people in but still keep your eyes
peeled for bullcrap the gun is also a
way to create some tension like imagine
them searching them later and then
finding the gun and saying hey I thought
we said no guns in here something kind
of like that it would cause conflict
with whoever's running the Alexandria
safe zone next question aaron s
did anyone else think that when Glenn
was working on the RV and knew about the
other battery it was a nod to Dale yeah
I think it was a total reference to Dale
on his RV any time you feel there's a
week get a character from a previous
season or someone who died someone who
they have really fond memories of its
totally reference they totally like to
do that it's totally intentional next
question little Hill asks do you think
that they're going to delve into the
safe zone characters more so than they
did in the comics do you think that
they'll start doing more branch story
lines such as the this group goes on a
DC run while Carl gets ready for school
so you're asking like are they gonna
adapt it a little bit more like they
won't do it exactly like the comics yes
I think they'll totally do that they'll
drill down on a couple specific safe
zone characters and then they'll have
certain members of the group go on side
trips every once in a while they'll
still totally do that thing where they
give certain members of the group solo
episodes we're like two characters go
off on their own like Daryl and Carol
get an episode that's mostly them and
very little of the others and then
they'll be like a Rick coral episode
Rick Michonne or Carl Michonne stuff
like that just because we haven't met a
lot of the new Alexandria safe zone
people I'm not going to talk about them
specifically but there are a couple key
people that we meet during that store in
line in the comics that I think that the
show will focus on next question Niko
asks do you think that Rick will get a
shave that beard is ridiculous that's
funny I know some people love the beard
some people think it's totally weird if
you look at it like on a high res TV you
can tell that it's definitely a fake
beard it totally does not look natural
at all Andrew Lincoln actually shaved it
a long time ago during the back half of
season for Andrew leaking just grew his
beard out his natural beard the last
couple of episodes though you could tell
he was definitely wearing a fake beard
it's like full-on Moses beard now he's
gonna part the Red Sea of Walker's he
might not shave it in this next episode
but definitely in the next couple weeks
definitely very very soon the beards
days are numbered next question Miguel
asks how long do you think that the
group is going to stay at Alexandria
will it be like the prison where they
had 30 days without an incident well I
do think though they'll be jumps in time
especially between seasons five and six
but I think that in terms of like big
locations they'll be there for a long
time that doesn't mean we won't see
other big locations like there are other
places in the comics that they go while
they're still at Alexandria but
Alexandria will be like their home base
it's not going
be like terminus where it blows up after
two episodes thank you everyone that
submitted questions these are always a
ton of fun to do generally pretty good
with the spoilers I know everyone's
asking about negan but I think he is
like mid season six I think what
everyone wants to see is them introduce
him at episode 100 or at least have like
a huge negan easter egg if they're not
ready to bring the character on next
week we'll meet some of the new
characters from the safe zone including
some of the new recurring characters
that'll that'll continue to appear for
the rest of the season so be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll post it
after the episode airs in
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Matt Hawk you in the twenty
dollar amazon gift card just messaged me
on my channel so I get your contact info
new episode of Gotham tonight so i'll
post that video after the episode airs
and in case you guys miss walking dead
because the Oscars you can click here
for my episode 11 video and you can
click here to get ready for Gotham thank
you so much watching so let's all high
five I'll see you guys tonight